over the next three months the omicron
variant is expected to account for three
billion infections worldwide that's as
many as during the entire pandemic so
far and yet there is optimism that this
may be the beginning of the end
i think the vaccines and drugs that are
now available can reduce covered burden
by over 95 percent so that it's no
longer a top 10 health problem
um
i think it's going to be very difficult
to actually get it under control in
terms of controlling cases so we're
talking about controlling severe disease
and reducing mortality massively
um so whilst there still will be cases
unfortunately
they will be much less severe overall
south africa where omicron was first
detected is now providing intriguing
clues about what may happen next
infection numbers there are dropping
fast in a population that's achieved
high levels of natural immunity down
more than 50 percent from their peak
restrictions are being lifted and a
number of international studies support
claims that omicron is less dangerous
confining itself more to the nasal and
upper respiratory passages than the
lungs
the infection numbers are enormous and
yet undeniably the public health
consequences are less severe so have we
genuinely reached a turning point well
plenty of scientists seem to think so
and even the world health organization
says that 2022 could bring an end to the
acute phase of the pandemic
but the world health organization
cautions that's possible only if the
vaccines and treatments available in the
rich world are made equally available to
all a goal the world is some way from
achieving
and even then scientific views are
divided
the omicron variant actually shows us
that this virus is very flexible the
omicron variant is so different to the
other variants that we've seen that it's
actually
um able to enter in cells in in
completely different ways from the ways
previous veins used to enter and what we
realize is that the space for adaptation
of this virus is quite large and as long
as transmission is allowed to continue
the course of the pandemic is going to
be very very unpredictable
high transmission rates raise other
concerns too the debilitating effects of
long covid the continued risk to the
vulnerable and the unvaccinated
increasingly though policy thinking
seems to be shifting away from long-term
control measures towards the view that
the vast majority of us may be able to
live alongside the virus eventually
posing as much risk to public health as
the flu
jonah al jazeera london